already we can start making plans for
christmas dinner smith's food and drug
store the sponsors of our next segment
has a great holiday ham recipe take a
look
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from smith
okay it's that time of year where you're
probably gonna be cooking a holiday ham
for whatever reason everybody always
does well i know we do but i'm going to
show you my method it's a i think it's
better than the usual way of just
throwing this big thing in the oven
putting some some glaze on the outside
but what happens is that glaze just all
runs down to the bottom and you don't
really get glaze on the ham which is a
weird way to do it so i'm going to show
you my way we're going to start by
making the glaze this is more method
than anything this glaze here is just
the recipe that i use you can use
whatever whatever glaze you you have or
you want to do but i'm going to melt
some butter there
and then into that butter i'm going to
go some garlic
and then let that kind of come down to
as it cooks but anyway the secret to
mine is that we're going to take the ham
off of the bone so what i'm going to do
is just start cutting it so we're this
is not been cooked or anything
it's been cooked i misspoke so all of
this ham they've they've already been
cooked you're just warming it basically
so what i want to do is just cut it into
into bite-sized pieces and put it in a
baking dish and just kind of layer it in
there
and then and then i'll show you what i'm
going to do with it next so let me just
go ahead and get this all cut down and
then we'll we'll move on
okay so i've almost got all that ham cut
off of the bone you have to do this
anyway so you might as well do it
beforehand so that you can get all the
flavor on all your ham so you can kind
of see where we're going with this
so our ham is all cut up already and the
way we want it to be and the purpose of
this is just so that every piece of ham
has flavoring and glaze on it rather
than just a few little pieces so
everybody gets a good one so we have our
butter and garlic going here and goes
some brown sugar
and then some nutmeg cloves
actually cinnamon cloves
dijon mustard
chicken broth
and then honey and again this this is
just my recipe you can put whatever
glaze you want to do for this and it
will be fantastic it's more of the
method than anything else so let me go
ahead and give that a stir and then this
is just going to go in the oven we're
going to cover it for the first probably
25 minutes at 375 and then we're going
to uncover it for the last maybe 10
minutes
just so it can kind of get the oven on
it there and get it nice and crispy on
top but you get the idea so i'm going to
get this covered
and i'm going to get it
in
the oven
so here we go
okay now this is done so remember the
last part of the cooking process i did
with the cover off
and so you can see that the glaze has
had an opportunity to penetrate every
last piece of ham in there which is
exactly what we want so this is how i
would serve it so just get it out of
there
put it on a big platter
like so
maybe we'll get some some of that glaze
and put on top of it let's dump it on
there why not
you can find all these ingredients at
your local smiths
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping and we will see you all
next time bye-bye everybody
all right that went fast if you want the
full recipe
for a smith's food and drugstore nearest
you go to smith's food and drug dot com